all right Tory is weather stories in
Lexington Kentucky hi Tory how are you
I'm good Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up to a car finance place
about October know anything about cars
so basically I ended up getting scammed
and I'm gonna end up paying $21,000 for
a 2007 Ford Focus and I really am at the
point where I don't want the car anymore
because my car payments are $400 a month
and I just don't want in the long run I
don't want to pay $21,000 for a car that
probably not going to work whenever I
get done paying for it so what were you
thinking at the time because you knew
all this when you signed up for it well
at the time I needed a car and that was
kind of the only place that I need to go
to look if I didn't have the money to
say that go buy a car I understand so if
you had that to do over you would just
not get a car right
yeah ride a bike yeah if you have to
before you do something stupid like this
again okay so the good news is you're
not really paying $21,000 you're not
going to keep the debt the whole time
and you're not going to pay all the
interest you're including all the
interest over the whole time you're on
the car and you're not gonna leave the
debt there that long even if you keep
this car so have you asked for the pay
off the pay off today yes
they financed 11,000 but with interest
and no there's no interest yet until
they until the loan you're paying them
interest monthly with your payment so
you don't have interest into the future
yet if you paid it off today what would
be the payoff it should be right around
eleven thousand or a little less yes yes
okay and what is the car worth today I'm
not completely sure where that's the
next piece of information let's pretend
you need to go to kbb.com that stands
for Kelley Blue Book calm
and pull up the information a private
sale there's three different pricings
retail wholesale and private sale
private sells when you sell the car to
an individual you pull that up and see
what the car is worth but you can sell
it for let's pretend that it's nine
thousand dollars that you could sell it
for okay but you owe them eleven
thousand dollars you following me yes
how old are you my team okay so you're
following me so far right yeah okay so
you're two thousand bucks in the hole we
got to get the two thousand bucks to get
you out of this mess and so you go over
the credit union you borrow two thousand
dollars you put two thousand dollars on
a credit card whatever you do you come
up with the two thousand bucks in our
example if you could sell it for nine
and let's say I was the buyer I come up
I give you a check for nine you put two
thousand on a credit card put two with
it you take the eleven over there you
pay them off they give you the title you
bring the title to the buyer what you
see how you get out of it yes and it's
not gonna be twenty four thousand you're
gonna go ahead and sell it now and eat
the difference but you got to figure out
a way to eat the difference with your
credit union your bank a credit card
some way that you eat the difference
okay that's thing one thing too is once
you have that information and you're
dealing with knowledge not with
intimidation I'd stroll back into the
tote the note lot where you bought this
and say guys I got to get out of this
I'm getting ready to hand you the keys
but instead of doing that can we just
work out a deal and I'll give you a
check and give you the keys and you go
away and I'll give you the car it's not
a repo you sell it back to them and
don't get repo'd you follow me yeah but
don't just take it over there and drop
it off because they'll sell it for six
thousand and sue you for the difference
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show and so you have to break the
cycle you have to flip this thing on its
head and make it behave you've got to
get so fired up and wired up that you're
broke friends think you've lost your